an update for you this afternoon this
evening emma berkey faced with severe
health challenges after getting the j j
vaccine she's now walking her family
shared this video recorded last friday
of the 19 year old able to walk up and
down stairs it's been a long 10 months
since berkey received her johnson and
johnson vaccine which she says caused a
series of rare health problems she also
says she has had to endure five
surgeries in total including three brain
surgeries with feeding and breathing
tubes as well as overcoming four strokes
that impacted both sides of her body
now i'm able to walk with
canes which i never thought that would
be able to happen anyway
so
i'm just
setting goals and hoping i reach them
and then when i reach them i come over
them
take a look at this picture that emma's
mom shared with us emma is holding a
baby doll it's a big deal for the teen
since she's working to get her upper
strength back on track since her dream
continues to be to work with children